what's happening there reject nation we
have ourselves the first episode of the boys
season three absolutely love this series last
time we covered the boys with olivia but we are
in the middle of moving this week so next week
you'll see a completely different background hey
i just wanted to mention first real quick it's the
boys so you know like depending on what level of
graphic imagery specifically with exposed body
parts we'll probably have to blur it because we
can't afford another community guidelines trick
right now uh just just as a heads up youtube is
not a fan of that secondly if you want to watch
the full length watch along uh uncut you can
watch over our patreon page over there
we cover many shows with the same tier
you get the option for reaction highlights and
watch longs included for some exclusive shows
if you don't want to do that please
leave a like and your comments down below
and also subscribe click that notification
bell to get notified when our next reaction
for the boys is up we're gonna try to play catch
up really fast before finally being moved out of
you lastly thanks to the boys of prep for helping
us add down these highlights with a show like this
i'm sure you're gonna have a lot of fun
you know making sure to work around certain
moments but the real last thing uh especially
for something like the boys uh where you're
really likely to not get monetization due to the
content that isn't it i want to thank storyblocks
for sponsoring this video uh we've been hiring
more people lately like people at prepper and
then you know people like coy and i got sally
coming back on partnering up with people like
storyblocks really helps us keep producing more
content and expanding the channel and doing stuff
like the boys i mean that sincerely so thank you
sorry blocks more on them right after the reaction
before she was fried stormfront i knew
you'd be here who's playing stormfront
join me and we can reign together
for a thousand years never
our children could be they would be the
best of both of us aryan kinderseldotten no
they'd be monsters like you your choice leaption
but not even you could stop
me alone he's not alone
yeah this movie actually seems pretty cool
i know i can't let you guys have all the fun
they should just start spinning these movies off
because he's back in the seven die winter mensch
oh they're at the premiere
it's not the stormfront you
know seth rogen utilized that
charlize there in connection to get her in here
huey is attending the premiere
really whacked away that whole
former fugitive image huh
when are we gonna see you on the track again real
soon but that race is coming full speed ahead for
the a train it's been over a year in the people
only questions about the movie thank you so much
that's going to be a great interview
another big dick energy bro
i have no idea good i didn't
give a [__] guys pig
oh my god everything we've been through
we'd be here together oh you sick bastard
what a photo op i am just the man
who fell for the wrong woman um
i found that little [__] we've been
on all month don't meet the boys we're
all set up we just need you to uh give us
a green light no violence or curb stomping
or setting anyone on fire okay expense reports
you wanted good to know he still works with him
amazon buying the kids some games
what oh my god
whoa whoa
now this guy would go up
thanos's butthole in a heartbeat
i want you inside me oh he means literally oh yeah
let's go all greatest voyage in here
oh man boys will be boys can't wait to
have a herogasm oh my god that's awesome
wow
this
oh
oh no i go right you can't leave oh no step on
oh god
get out get out get
he's out to get in my ass drop trail my god
yes way to go butcher
oh my god got this orders and put
that little [__] on his side wow
and we're back here we are back no questions
how surveillance goes with termite last night
you know i haven't checked in with butcher yet
but i'm sure it went fine i'll bet you a crisp
hundred dollar bill something got [__] up you
don't know that i'll go take the bet i'm i'm not
gonna take the bet but can i help you i'm just
waiting to see nadia that's congresswoman victoria
newman you're the wrong person we're best friends
i will give her the message this way
pal you were the guy at the premiere
you gonna bring him that connect four
i thought he was fighting for the boys
i gotta do something to pass the time oh
no he's happy to see him all right sweet
here you go never guess what it is oh she
watches over oh that's great good for you malory
i hear you've been on the straight and narrow all
year we even follow hugh campbell's orders without
strangling him now you're just being cruel i
know you're not doing all that for yourself
so then who the house i need
this equity it's great to see you
did you just have a slot before me yeah i'm
just stumping for my book deeper went awesome
deeper how did you give this lot before
me it was a [__] up mistake that talent
booker is so [__] fired i'm asking him i'm
asking you i don't know but it's ridiculous
good to see you
too sir so despairing it's the birthday girl
you're willing to have all this superhero stuff
yeah especially of the seven homeland i like
the hair and then damn photos photos you know
what so um happy birthday ginny happy birthday
you gotta move on marvin well you moved on with
todd or i'm sorry happy birthday to you oh oh no
you're a dork todd you're a dork homelander one
dose of this temporary bee gives a soldier 24
hours of powers give or take and if it's temporary
that means the dod has to keep buying doses and
how much you hit 2 million oh my god compound v is
radio [__] active it's not gonna fly in congress
i still have a few strings that i can pull in
congress okay so she works with him you and
i built this place and we did it the right
way without being covered in blood and guts
right so please just trust me but what
about that guy that keeps calling you nadia
tony we love tony we're outmanned and outgunned
and we've got to put them [__] in a box before
they do it to us if you would just compromise a
little compromise [__] you your whole life's
a compromise hey at least i have a [__]
life oh huey it's okay to stop to move on
she would have wanted you to oy
[__] wonder will you knock it off no
you have restored a wholesome trustworthy
image to the company when we needed it
the most which is why the board wants to
make you co-captain of the seven oh my god
your numbers are down what uh double digits the
public still associates you with storm front
this would be a real bump oh my god oh
jesus could you give us a moment look
i really like to keep discussing this absolutely
set a time with samantha and we'll get you in
real power isn't this it's the
ability to bend the world to your will
authority to fill the team's empty slots wow
really i am offering you real power real change
oh my god she can make it what she dreamed
of before all this happened that was crazy
everything's looking up for everyone this season
ain't nothing bad going to happen in any of
the ensuing episodes literally thousands of
tortured souls who are trapped in that
church right now who want to escape just
like me and my wife did it's very brave thank
you your book deeper has been a game changer
oh my god annie and i snuck into a cantina
and they had those i mean those yards of
margarita i must have drank a quarter mile
shall we bring out starlight to do a number
and she just pukes in front of a festival crowd
i had no idea you drank back then oh yeah miss
kitty two shoes she had a fun side big time nice
tell me more you've known him your whole
life and you know took your virginity so
why would i worry okay it was a mutual taking
of virginity's and you know what it happened
so long ago and only a couple of times and we
weren't married so it felt weird having sex
drummer boy didn't like to
pound it you know what i mean
sex drums and i could make trouble at fought
do some real good or homelander could murder
you someone needs to stand up to this guy and
that has to be you not just me i mean i could
bring good people into the seven who could
help me wait you mean like your boyfriend
no one even bats an eye when a man climbs the lap
okay you're right you're right you're
right look i'm i'm sorry i'm sorry
see you later tonight don't bother with
the aquafresh i would bring it just in case
oh my god he is just getting stripped
i feel like homeland emasculated
god just the faces he's pulling this
episode or what are you drinking
shake shack oh you want one i'll go grab
a piece oh no no thank you though yeah
i see you got the extra whipped cream in there
no man he's judging him no no no no you know
i need 30 000 calories a day maybe when you
actually ran you did but now you're just eating
your feelings making us look ridiculous
the fastest man alive what a [__] joke
what did you say oh oh damn
that's really well directed yeah
sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
ultimate eavesdropper are we
looking out for homelanders
victims they texted butcher today uh they
made starlight co-captain my poor baby
i don't know how much more of this i could
take no one suffers like you suffer let me help
you honestly i have to put up with
these no no no month after month
they took myself from me so pathetic oh my
god i'm so pathetic i think i have something
oh if we can find this weapon or whatever it is
maybe we can use it to blow
homelanders [__] brains out here
holy crap she snatched it
this is our best chance to kill homelander
don't [__] it up it's only 24 hours
dad they've wasted no time in this no i love it
may i come in
there there wasted no time i love this i love it
so much can we just skip to the part where your
laser my [__] brains out where's the sport
in that you're like putting down a wounded dog
you're the one with your tail between
your legs and all the [__] talk shows
well what if we share a different destiny
only one of us left standing
isn't that what you want
too [__] right
i look forward to it
got this feeling in my buns
that's crazy that scene
happened in the first episode
oh man
oh he's already like on top of it nadia hey nadia
oh huey's gonna witness the wrong thing
hey tony are you been oh [__]
he's gonna witness the wrong thing
we should tell everyone you have a
platform now we should tell everyone
about red river it's not that
easy tony tony i can't please
yep there it is
whoa
oh
good
you might as well obliterate his whole face
and blow his whole yeah blow his whole body up man
oh my god put him out of his misery
i need a team alleyway east 12th and broadway
crazy what a crazy good first episode
damn well done back with a bang what a
crazy good first episode yeah i was like i
first would probably have to take a while to
get it going and i was like oh man they're like
full steam that was great that was awesome well
yeah guys got a lot to say about this one i can
really feel it uh thank you for sticking
around before we jump into our review a
couple of quick words about storyblocks thank
you again for sponsoring this video because uh
partnering up with you guys really helps us
out right now with everything we got planned
thank you to storyblocks for sponsoring this
video being the cinematic artisans we obviously
are we are always in search of ways to make our
videos look better faster and most of all for
cheap cheap is good and if you're a content
creator or filmmaker or anything in between
you're probably in a similar position it's tough
to get your content looking as good as it can be
without breaking the bank or burning yourself out
in the process which is why i heavily encourage
you guys to check out what storyblocks has to
offer cheap is good do you feel like this is
their way of telling us that the videos could be
looking better yes whether it's the credibility of
an exotic establishing shot the soothing comfort
of the perfect music bed or just the satisfaction
of increasing your graphical capability storybox
has an incredibly inclusive and diverse library
of faces places sounds titles transitions filters
and effects and more over a million assets royalty
free and available for personal and commercial use
with your membership sounds so affordable this is
quite affordable they have multiple subscription
levels to suit your exact needs whether you're
an independent indie solo creator or a whole team
so if you want to learn more head on down to our
link in the description box and get started that's
at storyblocks.com rejects now back to the video
all right well we don't have to talk for
too long because we've got more to get to
but um yeah for a pilot i thought uh not
pilot for the first episode of season three
a premiere i thought this was really solid you
know like season two picked up pretty much right
after and this uh takes place like since it wasn't
right after but it was a much smaller time span
and this one takes place uh i believe a year
after the events of season one and uh season
two i'm getting all my seasons mixed up here and
uh i really appreciate just how full of force
uh they went with it just how gonzo it already
is you know like i remember when season two
premiered people felt like it was taking a while
to get going and there was because they had they
they switched from instead of releasing them all
at once three at a time and then weekly and then
here i was like it's probably gonna be the
same thing you know like probably the good
stuff wouldn't happen until episode three and wow
they like the this started off with what's that uh
not tremor tremor nah termite turmeric
sorry halfway uh termite at the very top was
mind blowing yeah like oh my god they just they
are showing that like and they're supposed to be
here orgasm this season so i was like this is
gonna be that is what they're kicking off with
i can only imagine how far it's gonna go and
uh showing us where we are with our characters
um at this point in the story of they're no
longer fugitives they get to have their own the
the lives they have now they're choosing to
have these lives you know um like huey gets
to be with starlight and work for uh newman
which is a fascinating setup because he's got
to be putting together that oh my god i mean he
didn't quite see what happened yeah but he might
be able to piece together that exploding heads and
exploding from what happened last season that must
maybe that was her this whole time because
we never got confirmation of who that was
that must be this person you know it seems like
he'd be sharp enough to at least get on that scent
or they at least wonder it yeah because too
i mean she's calling teams to come clean this
up like he's gotta at least be suspect of her in
some degree yeah and the setup too with stan edgar
um it's it's cool hopping back and forth between
better call saul and this where you got you know
giancarlo esposito playing two head honcho bad
guys who run organizations that are on the front
look like something that's completely completely
different you know and i i like seeing more of
his um quandary that he's in here because
he's you get a better insight into how he
really feels towards the soups because he always
said he said at the beginning of season two that
this isn't a superhero but this is a
pharmaceutical industry or something
like that that's that's the game they're
playing and as he uh brings that back
in this conversation and now that makes more
sense now it's clearer of the direction that
they really wanted to go not just put soups in the
military but really control soldiers uh with this
comp this v24 thing that they have going on but i
love i love the way his scenes are handled because
when the doors are open it's a very different
personality you see it twice in this episode
the doors are open it's the stan edgar that
he puts on and then when the doors are closed
it's just like i'm sick of this here's how
i'm really feeling yeah yeah yeah so you can
get charming but not the facade yeah you get to
see a different side to stan anchor here and um
so i appreciate the setup there this whole
thing with starlight that's going to be
really fascinating i feel like maybe that jealousy
thing will be the thing that which is huey to get
like maybe i'll take the v24 you know yeah
it's gotta happen at some point plus to see
hughie take on whatever powers he's gonna get
like you know what's gonna happen with butcher
we've seen a little bit of that in the trailers
but i'm excited to see i i can imagine the whole
team getting on at some point yeah you know and
really getting to see the fun and games of that
i know in the comics they eventually all do
i believe but i i mean i i don't know where
the direction of this show will go because it's
already so different in a lot of ways um because
i like what they've done with butcher you know i
thought that with the way season two ended that
ryan would just be kind of on off of his own and
we wouldn't really see him yeah and to know that
butcher still is like step dad or surrogate father
to him in some ways or like i'm like uncle butcher
in a lot of ways um to this whole situation
like ryan running up to him and embracing him
with enthusiasm and butcher hugging him back is
something i wasn't expecting that was a really
heartfelt moment because i thought he would still
have this like level of reprieve with him where he
doesn't want a connection because of who he is
but to see that butcher is you know willing to
to be there for ryan and move past the horrendous
events and knowing who you know ryan's truly the
son of i think was a really uh really touching
thing and and the challenge of butcher having to
work with authority work with law be governed
is is interesting and they still keep it on the
the path of yeah it's like it's always been his
journey is always something associated with becca
and now it's this disdain and turmoil this
rage that is working off of off of the loss
of becca um after all that's happened and now to
be in the position he's in now like to have that
scene with homeland or just it's something so
surprising because you don't really get a lot
of homelander and butcher together even though
butcher's always that's the bullseye for him
that's the target and then so to start your season
off with us with a really tense taught scene
at the top of this at the very end of
this episode of foreshadowing a a a
feeling of what their final showdown might be like
uh was very fascinating and very compelling and
yeah the trailer gave away like the first thing
in the trailers giveaways that he's going to take
the v24 yeah that's the first thing so yeah um
but yeah how are you feeling about homelander
and all that i love that i love that a lot and
i thought that on top of everything they built
prior in the episode itself you know everything we
see with butcher everything we see with homelander
i thought it was a really beautifully twisted yeah
character beat emotional moment to have it be that
in a way i swear it looks like homelanders
like even though he's not really opening up
to butcher he's like the one person it's the one
exchange where it feels like they're on sort of
a level of some kind and he's identifying and i
think that's a really cool note for both those
characters because as much as they hate each other
and represent the sort of polar opposites in a way
they also kind of are at this stage in time the
only people who can kind of understand what each
other is sort of dealing with which i think is is
beautiful in a show that gets you know obviously
twisted in terms of its action and in terms of
its various pulpy elements uh you know that is
something really harsh and nasty but also like
touching in a in a dark way yeah and i appreciated
that uh very much and this was a an episode in
an entirety that it's like last season we were
sitting there going yeah i see why they released
three episodes because they're like now it feels
kind of like we're at the start whereas here i was
like i could wait a week for the next one and be
totally satisfied with this as the premiere which
i think is great which i think is really strong
and i think they're doing a nice job of yeah
really laying down the place of here's where
everybody is a year later you know here are some
shifted power dynamics here are some people who
are estranged and it felt like everybody got just
enough time to really feel like the ensemble is
back and reestablished and we know where all the
pieces are but we're also pretty connected like i
thought pretty much every plot line was pretty
engaging and pretty engrossing and i love just
the sick and twisted web of influence and tension
that there is with homelander and everybody under
homelander and everybody who's now above homeland
yeah on the food chain and uh yeah i mean i'm i'm
very curious to see how that interplay uh goes
down with vot and the newman campaign because
obviously they are connected obviously they are
playing ball and the trailers do give away that
thing too of huey being like well you know i try
to do it the legit way it's not working but uh
you know i wonder what commentary is gonna arise
from that too because you know that's obviously a
big part of i heard a great little uh take on this
that like the comics of the boys go so far as to
um deconstruct and comment on superhero
comics whereas the show is about superhero
visual media shows and movies uh more so
i said that in the last trailer reaction
oh is that what you said yeah oh great well
then i you never heard it from anybody else
i don't know i don't think so then i stole it from
you that's even better that's pretty sure it might
just be a common opinion i don't know i mean yeah
i i it seemed said with authority and it seemed
also like something that i think is very evident
when you look at them and you look at them side
by side did i take it from someone i don't know
i don't think so i don't think it's a takeable i
don't i don't think it's a point where it's like
uh you stole that it's more like i remember when
i said that i was like i think i just came up with
an interesting point then you probably did it but
i'm pretty sure now i'm like but i probably took
that from someone else no i mean hey in in in week
to week time watch a lot of stuff must have taken
it from someone else i don't think so i'm pretty
sure i did i think something in my back of mine's
like no i think i took that from someone else
even if you did even if you arrived at
it independently or not it's very good
i appreciate it you know we'll go back
pretty sure it's been a common opinion
so i you know you see so many things in a week
sometimes things blur together as to where
but anyhow i i feel like they do a really
great job of deconstructing that stuff
but they also do happy rockstar said it
okay that sounds sounds reasonable too
i mean it's a good point overall and nobody
always care about giving proper credit you know
scared about even proper credit if i've heard
it from someone i think it was them or heavy
spoilers maybe i'm not sure all right what
does it matter continue i heard it from you
and then the rest is up to you to figure out
but either way uh yeah that that being that
this is the more sort of cinematic uh breakdown
of superheroes and whatnot uh i feel like too
there could probably be because this is
being made at a slightly different time be
some interesting updates on the you know
the conversations surrounding money power
politics and etc um and i feel like the show
generally does a nice job at incorporating all
that stuff and i am excited to see how that grows
here too well it seems like with homelander that
is going to be uh you know buddying up with the
storm chasers who are representing uh you know
an alt-right section of the world yep um i'm not
sorry that's what the show's doing okay so yeah
so yeah like that's what uh that's it's that's
because homelander always goes where he feels
loved and accepted that's where he gravitates
towards always and so i'm sure he's gonna
find the catharsis uh with that group even
though he's like no none of this aryan stuff
which which is you know maybe not
what that group is directly saying um
however they are going to be the representative
factor even budding up with this i forget the
guy's name but the one who resembles tucker
carlson oh yeah yeah the deep navin has come back
slowly deeper i think it's a funny ass title
uh a train struggling with a weight loss issues
that's i think there's some really great
directed moments you know like i like the
when he whispers [__] you and the way they
kept it in one shot like you got to have like
really good timing because as actors anthony
starr anthony starr has to be like he probably
couldn't actually hear him yeah you know and so
he had to somehow be cute or had to be so timed
to the point where he could hear him i don't know
how they did that yeah or even the way they showed
with mother's milk uh marvin when they when
and when uh it looks like oh he's got his whole
family together he's got his wife back where she
always you know last season was like i'm leaving
you i'm leaving you you know this is enough you
keep saying you're dumb you're back in and you
lied to me than to have the todd guy come in and
you're like oh that's a good visual way of just
showing us you know so i thought there were
some really just great directed moments and
i mean the way that he opened up the closet was
like is his butcher going in there and planting
[__] yeah like look what we got more is he
just doing is i imagine he just he just can't
truly let it go yeah yeah and then the question
becomes yeah is he doing this in coordination
with butcher or just he just knows what needs
to be done and he's already doing the leg work
yeah yeah but this was an amazing first episode
loved it we gotta hop on to the next one guys
uh leave your thoughts down below what did you
think about this pilot and also you know gimmick
i like that because she's a mute and
then she you know she lives in the
music the musical mind that's a cool way to
express uh how she's really feeling and so
more piano more piano so yeah i
really think this is all great stuff
and uh subscribe click that bell
keep a look out for our next reaction
we'll see you guys soon you